better late than never I'm going to uh
open the uh meeting of the joint
committee on employee classification
and we everybody should have the agenda
there and the first thing is to
review and approve the minutes of the
March the 10th meeting so I don't know
if anybody
second that's moved by uh Senator
Rosenwald second by representative
Schmidt any discussion Corrections or
anything
okay
um the vote is to approve the minutes uh
Senator Abbas
Senator Rosenwald
represent uh Schmidt and uh chair votes
yes so the uh minutes have been approved
and then the first
item is uh concerning the deputy
director division of Behavioral Health
if somebody can come up and speak to
that
good morning I'm Lori spring I'm the
Workforce Development administrator for
the Department of Health and Human
Services
and Nathan white Chief Financial Officer
with the Department of Health and Human
Services
of an existing institution to fill a new
role within the department the division
of Behavioral Health Services currently
is the only division at HHS that does
not have a deputy director position
um and with various expansions it's a
role that's sorely needed to be able to
attend to operational oversight and
day-to-day management of the division
um
so this is a vacant position
that we are asking for the grade of GG
okay
questions or discussion on this and I
was going to get my
you know some people people an idea of
what this
is someone here I've got
um
just so people know what GG is that's uh
you know these are all salary ranges and
this is a range from 79 430 up to 110
682.
I don't have anything any questions
comments corn fairy recommends the GG so
and that that's that's our Criterion and
it is right in line so I'm happy to move
uh approval of this item second all
right
um there's no further discussion we
could do the vote uh Senator Abbas
Senator Rosenwald
representative Schmidt yes and the chair
boats yes so that's um
order zero who adopt that one all right
thank you
and the next one is uh director of
Medicaid policy and clinical
programs
okay this is also Health and Human
Services position this is another new
function within the department
these duties were currently or were
previously performed by the deputy
director of Medicaid services however
scope and population served have
expanded and so we have a need to have a
dedicated position to oversee both
policy and clinical programming within
Medicaid and our recommended letter
grade is FF
okay and um
oh here it is on the back I was looking
to see
what all is under them
and again for uh people's information FF
is
73 580 to 102 518. and I assume you know
where they people fall in there depends
on their experience and
what it takes to hire somebody I guess
yeah our recommendation and I believe
corn Ferry's analysis is based on a
number of factors but it does include
recommended education and experience to
be successful in the role right okay uh
Senator Abbas
sorry it's my first time
I understand recruitment has been a kind
of a struggle Statewide on a lot of
different places for this position
particularly I think it's going to be an
important one going forward
are you confident that you can recruit
with that income bracket or that pay
scale
we do feel confident that this is an
appropriate range given the requirements
for the position
thank you and uh Senator Rosenwald
is this a position that you could
recruit from inside the department for
I think we could certainly potentially
have internal candidates that would
always be you know the optimal
experience would so somebody who already
knows the Medicaid Program
exactly I mean knowledge of Medicaid
policy is is a critical function in this
role so to have someone who already
understands Medicaid policy in New
Hampshire would be the ideal
so other than somebody who's already in
working for the Department
you know what kind of other
experience or background would give
somebody that so what's kind of the pool
you could recruit from I'm just curious
again we're looking for a depth of
experience in policy generally strategic
planning so we are looking for a
candidate with a background in public
Administration health administration
prior experience and health network
so that would be I think the primary
pool and again ideally we would be
identifying an internal candidate that
we would
promote to fulfill this role sure and if
you find somebody who has some
experience in that and has a larger
experience but doesn't know all the
details of how Medicaid Works in New
Hampshire are there people already in
the department working would be working
under him who have a lot of experience
with that absolutely
um yeah our State Medicaid director is
extremely knowledgeable and the core
team within clinical policy or excuse me
clinical programs is strong in
experience
sure and and uh of course it this would
be an unclassified position all
unclassified positions would be posted
externally as well so so it's not
classified so it doesn't go through an
internal posting first it it would go
external
um last year we recently hired somebody
external to the department that did have
a lot of skills and experience in the
Medicaid field within Medicaid and they
brought in a wealth of experience and I
think also bringing in um
bringing the experience from other
states or national experience is really
helpful for New Hampshire because they
can give us alternatives to the way that
we're doing things right now so while
there are definitely benefits of hiring
internally if there is a is indeed a
qualified individual but B an individual
who's interested in taking on an
unclassified position which is a little
bit different than a classified role
that could be beneficial but there's
also benefits to having folks come from
external
um and and as indicated earlier we
believe that at this labor grade we
would we would be able to attract an
individual whether it be internal or
external to the state to be successful
in this role any other questions or
discussion
okay I'd accept emotion
okay all right so it's been moved and
seconded to approve this request Senator
Abbas yes yes Senator Rosenwald Senator
Schmidt yes and the chair about CS so
that's four to zero all right thank you
Anna you're also up for the next one
this is executive director of the
prescription drug affordability board
and um
so the department recommended HH
which would have been
86 yeah 86 502 to 125.62
and corn Ferry said GG which is the next
one down 79 430 to 110 682
so any any comments on that or nature of
the position
or and and I believe I thought
representative Merchant was going to be
here to speak to this so just to clarify
the prescription drug affordability
board I believe a legislation was passed
in 2021 to establish the sport
um the board is administratively
attached to the department so the
department does not oversee the
day-to-day functions instead it's it's
administratively attached to us they
operate independently
um I I cannot speak to the specifics of
the program I approach things more from
the financial side I can give you all
the history there if you'd like it
um but I do know when I have heard
represent representative Merchant speak
to the qualifications of a director for
this type of role that it's going to be
challenging to find somebody who's
qualified because they may need to have
uh they may need to have a background
within the pharmaceutical industry they
may need to have a background in in law
as well which is why we had originally
come forward with a with a higher
request than what corn fairy had
recommended just because we do
anticipate finding or the board the
prescriptions of affordability board
anticipates a difficult time finding a
qualified individual to to run the
functions of that board
so there hasn't been anybody in this
position
today no this is this is a brand new
um the the budget currently includes
funding for for this position as it
currently stands with the Senate that
this would be brand new
uh Senator Rosenwald thank you I'm a
member of this board
so
um I do know that it took the state of
Maryland
about 18 months to hire someone it's
kind of a specialized feel but but I
hesitate to go against corn fairy
because I think they
seem to somehow know what they're doing
so if they recommend GG
all right uh did you have a comment
representative Schmidt well of course uh
representative Merchant the chair is a
former member of Edna as the chair and I
are uh he's been before us uh in
committee on on this issue uh and this
is a vital position that's one of the
reasons as Senator Rosenwald undoubtedly
knows well one of the reasons that uh
prescription uh drug affordability board
is not as functional as it needs to be
you know what I have in this person now
this is still a very substantial salary
uh and but I see the commissioner
coming up to give us some additional
guidance yeah I'm uh actually fairly
familiar with this thing and in full
disclosure although it won't affect my
decision here I I have made attempts to
abolish the board but
an amendment I tried to get through not
this year but
um
thank you what attempts have been made
to actually recruit someone before this
position
my understanding is that it so it can't
be posted because no salary has been set
and that's the process you're undergoing
now I would say that um and I you know I
don't know what exactly what the board's
going to do and I understand the
position they are looking for something
of a unicorn
um you know it'd be great to find a
lawyer who's also a pharmacist I think
would be like Eagle right
and that's unlikely I I wanted to talk a
little bit about corn fairy and what
they do and how that process works for
for members of the committee who aren't
so corn fairy examines positions by by
content they don't make any effort to
determine whether the salary is an
appropriate salary for recruitment
they do no market analysis at all in
fact it's part of what they do is they
don't do market analysis they make no
effort on that the all the unclassified
positions in the state are placed into a
grid based on their complexity versus
all the other state positions and
whether we pay those positions
you know 30 more 20 less or whatever but
no all you know is that ggs are
similarly complex that the committee has
in the past
um
periodically made adjustments
um to salaries based on issues like
recruitment for example the medical
examiners historically are not a very
complicated
I mean nobody wants to do it but it's
not as complicated as some job so their
salary came in
probably like GG or something and they
make more than anybody else in state
government they make like double what
the governor makes or something like
that and uh and so the committee the
committee does that and so typically
what what committees have done in the
past is look at it and say okay corn
fairy has said based on complexity
points Gigi is about where they are
um it would be unusual for the committee
to deviate from that by more than a
letter grade but it would not be unusual
for the committee to deviate from that
by a letter grade
um historically people have looked at it
and said well you know what this
position is going to be harder to
recruit financially for reasons that are
legitimate not just that because frankly
all of us can sit up here at some point
and go well we're having a really hard
time hiring
I mean frankly everything right from
building cleaners to engineers and
um but in this in this case what
committee says has historically done is
looked at it and said are there things
about this position that make it
particularly I don't say weird what's
the word I'm looking for
um unusual or anomalous and and that's
something you would look at and I say
that to say that even corn fairy would
tell you they're not meant to be
um biblical in their Authority
we went higher because we needed
somebody in that position and when we
went higher we got some
yeah my understanding is there is
somebody doing that and he makes a lot
of money
actually these
the salary range for that is uh
well there is no range it's one amount
and it's 176 696. yeah that's one of the
off-the-grid positions so to speak
I say that not because I I'm not on the
affordability board I've talked to
represent a merchant I don't know but my
understanding is they are looking for a
bit of a unicorn it's going to be very
hard to recruit
any other comments uh Senator Evans
thank you it's more of a general
question but if the corn fairy hay
recommendation sounds like their
analysis can be
flawed depending on the context it's in
why are we going to take that rely on
their recommendations going forward
it's a good question their analysis
isn't flawed as much as it's limited
um their uh classification is a is a
complicated thing
um in employee well employee
classification generally and it it and
there are multiple ways to do it the
truth is that most people and and most
of it in America dates back a little
over 100 years to some to the
Philadelphia Transit company but
um there are
there are ways to do it the most
important way to do any classification
is based on job content and and that is
to say that uh you know markets
fluctuate up and down and we can look at
things but when you're doing a system
where you're taking hundreds of
thousands of employees and trying to
align them all against each other I mean
think of it if you've got a smallish
business and there's five people working
for you you can be like
yeah I'll give you 10 this year and and
and Senator you'll get eight
um or I could reverse that if if one of
you is offended but um the uh but but
you sort of go along that way and and uh
what we've hired them for and frankly
that's what the division of personnel
does to the classified system is to
examine job content and so they're
coming to you with that and nine times
out of ten or 95 times out of a hundred
job content is going to get you the
employee to the place where they are
neither heart uh harder or easier to
recruit than average right when when you
know during recession no State positions
are very hard to recruit during good
Economic Times All State positions are
hard to recruit and it's sort of a
truism of of the waiting at labor market
works but there are always going to be
one-offs and so what they're hired to do
is to do a
um
a non-economic evaluation so
I think
here's my take on it and correct me if
this is not correct correct um there's
um there's sort of two aspects of this
one is
how does the
difficulty complexity level experience
and everything needed for this job
compared to other jobs in the state
and having that lined up for one thing
would avoid issues where two people who
are doing kind of more or less the same
thing or paid widely wildly differently
which could cause problems
but so they help with that
but the for each classification how much
they're going to get paid or the salary
range is basically up to the legislature
you know you can request it now it's a
disc committee that would propose
adjusting those numbers the actual
dollar amount or what would be the
process of that they're not suggesting
that now but to understand when you say
adjusting the actual dollar amount uh on
the on the uh
the salary range for each grade
um how does that get set that gets set
by Statute and so typically that gets
set during Collective like um when
collective bargaining happens there's a
there's a bill that follows it okay um
this year it happens to be in-house Bill
2 where salaries are adjusted as a
result of that
unclassified are not part of collective
bargaining but typically that it's
extended to collective bargaining so for
example this year the the bill has that
these ranges will also go up by 10 or 2
or in the second year or whatever okay
Senator Roswell so does that mean that
if we were to
stick with them
thank you
and I want to speak to you
I'm going to be the acting person
yeah she didn't hear oh okay
um
okay
time being 9 31 we will open up our May
18th meeting of long-range Capital
planning and utilization committee to
the members in the audience I want to
welcome you to Public Works and highways
the first item on our agenda is the
acceptance of minutes from April 21st
2023 as distributed are there questions
comments omissions move to a proof
motion by Senator Lang to approve second
by second second by senator delisandro
my informality catches up with me at
times and I have to think of Sandra's
last name so thank you
um so that's old business there is none
we will move on to uh I think we need to
vote oh I'm sorry if you're if you're in
favor of the uh emotion to accept the
minutes signified by saying aye aye
those opposed
nay there are none uh passage
unanimously
uh we'll move on to uh item
23015 Department of Transportation
request authorization selling easement
over state-owned land on the southern
side of the Harris Pond Road in the town
of Merrimack
thank you Mr chairman Steve Labonte I'm
the administrator of the Bureau of
right-of-way with the Department of
Transportation the department requests
authorization to sell an easement over
state-owned land on the southern side of
Harris Pond Road in the town of
Merrimack the sale will be direct
to the Lansing group uh Lansing
Melbourne group for sixty one hundred
dollars which includes the Eleven
Hundred Dollar administrative fee the
sewer easement will be a means of
connecting an existing sewer line
located on the partial identified
in uh towns tax records as map one e lot
3 to a proposed Building located on
parse on parcel identified as map 1D lot
1-6 as depicted
on the plan that's in your packet
the sewer easement will be approximately
150 feet long by 20 feet wide and will
be for the
installation of an
eight inch gravity sewer line the
underlying parcel was acquired in 1988
for the Nashua Hudson
circumferential Highway project the
department acquired
19.16 acres of land from Harris Pond
Development Corporation by eminent
domain the matter was later settled for
seven thousand six hundred and thirteen
thousand three hundred dollars this
easement will be conveyed with the
following conditions
the grantee will be required to get a
commission a licensed land surveyor in
the state of New Hampshire to survey and
prepare a plan depicting the easement's
location the grantee will also be
responsible to obtain all local and
state land use approvals
precedent to the closing
right-of-way appraiser from the
Department prepared contributory value
appraisal using sales comparison
approach and opine that the value as of
April 25th 2003 was five thousand
dollars that with the administrative fee
brings us to 6100. thank you any
questions Mr Lamonte
seeing none uh is there a movie move to
approved 2315. thank you
um motion to move
is by Senator Lang
um seconded by Lou D'Alessandro any
further discussion
if you're in favor of to the approval of
23 0-15 signify by saying aye
aye any opposed
seeing non-passes unanimously
if we could move now to
23016 Department of Transportation
authorization Grant access point through
limited right-of-way on Route 4 at Old
Bruce Road
please thank you Mr chairman the
department requests authorization to
Grant an access point through the
limited access right-of-way on New
Hampshire Route 4 at Boyce Road in the
city of Concord to Robert and Mary Ann
Wolfe for 44 100 which includes the
Eleven Hundred Dollar administrative fee
the city of Concord developed plans to
upgrade the intersection of old Boyce
Road in in New Hampshire Route 4 in
Whitney Road by constructing a
roundabout with the limited access with
a limited Frontage of their parcel on
Old Boyce Road and the limited access
right-of-way boundary across that
Frontage the parcel will be landlocked
without granting this access point the
department acquired the abutting 12
acres of land from Richard and Edna
Sanborn in 1958 for 13 520 via warranty
deed the land acquired was improved with
a four-room house which was sold via
public auction in subsequently
subsequently removed
the this point of this access point will
be conveyed with the following
conditions grantees shall be required to
apply for a driveway permit through the
Department's District Five office and
shall follow the Department's driveway
permit policy grantee shall be
responsible for all local and state land
use approvals
mm-hmm because staff appraiser from the
Department opine that the contributory
value to the wolf's property as of
October 7 2022 was forty three thousand
dollars
thank you any further questions
move to approve uh 2316. motion uh made
by Lang section by D'Alessandro uh for
the approval of item 23016 any further
discussion
seeing none if you're in favor of the
motion you'll signify by saying aye aye
those opposed seeing none motion passes
uh accepted unanimously
and we will move to item
23017 authorization to Grant 15 30
square feet of Maintenance easement
state-owned land limited access
right-of-way located
I-95 exit one uh town of Seabrook
thank you Mr chairman as you just
mentioned the department Quest
authorization to Grant a 1530 square
foot maintenance easement on state-owned
land within the limited access
right-of-way located on the east or east
side of New Hampshire well not New
Hampshire I-95 exit one Northbound ramp
and the southerly side of the New
Hampshire route 107 U.S Route 1 in the
town of Seabrook the easement will be
granted to BJ's Wholesale Club
Incorporated for two thousand twenty
three hundred dollars which includes the
1100 administrative fee the department
acquired the property in the area of the
easement in 1967 for the interstate
route 95 New Hampshire route 107
construction project the parcel will be
conveyed with the following condition
that the buyer will be required to
commission a license land surveyor
licensed in the state of New Hampshire
to survey prepare a plan depicting the
easement a staff appraiser from the
Department of pine that the contributory
value to the abutting property as of
March 3rd 2023 was twelve hundred
dollars thank you any any questions
23 17.
um Senator Lang moves to approve item
seconded by Senator Pearl nice to have
you
um any further discussion
if you're in favor of the motion to
approve
23017 signified by saying aye aye if
you're opposed nay seeing no Nays passes
unanimously
um our we will move on to
23019 disposal of real estate department
environmental services
request authorization to sell its York
Dam and canal dam on the credit
River in Concord
gentlemen introduce yourself
good morning chairman and members of the
committee my name is Corey Clark I'm the
chief engineer at the dam Bureau at DES
morning everyone Mark Sanborn assistant
commissioner at DES
thank you and Mr Clark is it this is a
new position for you yes it is I took
over for Jim Gallagher in uh December or
he retired in December of last year and
I recently took over he was uh he was a
wonderful asset for our state
um did a lot of work in my region and
we're looking forward to working with
you please uh if you could uh present
your proposal here sure
um so New Hampshire Department of
Environmental Services is looking to
dispose of the York Dam and Associated
structures easements
um and flow adjustments to uh Briar
Hydro Associates
the the site is made up of four
structures and five easements we have
the York canal dam which is on the main
stem of the Kentucky River in Concord uh
in Penacook and uh then we have the
canal Dyke which is a historic structure
on basically an old Canal that was used
during uh for meal purposes
the uh Rolf Canal gate stem which is at
the entrance of the current Canal that's
used by Briar Hydro Associates uh to
allow water to flow down to their
hydroelectric facility and then also in
easement along that Canal for what was
that one time called the Ralph canal dam
that was removed in 1980. these
structures and easements were
transferred to the state in 1967
by the city of Concord and the Water
Resources board rebuilt the York Dam
which is the dam on the main stem using
their Force account in
1968. the site was redeveloped by Briar
Hydro Associates in 1986 and at that
point in time Elise was entered a
50-year lease with Briar Hydra
Associates for uh operation and
maintenance of the site at that time
Briar Hydra associates also built the
Rolf Canal gate stem at the on the state
of New Hampshire easement at the
entrance to the canal and since that
time Briar Hydro has been operating the
site of the hydroelectric facility
prior Hydro uh would like to purchase
the sites and transfer the easements to
them for uh six hundred thousand dollars
and the site was assessed in 2020 by the
New Hampshire Department of Revenue
Administration Municipal and property
appraisal division and they came out
with the the six hundred thousand dollar
estimate and
basically the reason we're doing this is
we currently uh as you know we lease the
site to Briar Hydro Associates we do
receive revenue from that lease however
by uh disposing of the site and selling
it to Briar Hydro it reduces the state's
liability for this site and removes one
of 60 High Hazard dams off our current
inventory so we can um help reduce the
state's risk and liability associated
with the site so and I'll just like to
add that's
um it's funny you mentioned Jim uh Corey
taking over for Jim we actually have
used this
um as an opportunity to kind of
reevaluate our portfolio the 275 dams we
own and the uh amount of capital needs
and
um the ongoing operation and maintenance
it would require it this sale is very
consistent with
um our goal is to drastically reduce the
amount of dams the state owns
you know if there there isn't a safety
or another state policy mitigating
reason to own a dam where you're gonna
we're gonna be over the next couple
years looking for options and other
opportunities to find other owners of
these dams find other options for these
dams because right now we have 275 dams
440 million dollars of capital needs and
that doesn't even count on going o m so
this is very consistent with how we
would like to start moving forward with
our overall portfolio
thank you commissioner they further
questions
um yes thank you Mr Stewart uh I know
the condition of our dibs uh is is not
up to par what what is the condition of
this of this site as as we speak
this site is actually in in pretty good
shape it's been um basically uh all the
O M costs and maintenance costs and
capital
um input into the site has been done by
Briar as required under their ferc
license that they have for this entire
site and the lease so it's this site is
is in Fairly good shape and I believe
Breyer is planning on continuing to
operate the site as they currently do
and just really quickly follow up on
that that's an example of why we want to
move to this model this is a dam
currently being leased that has value to
a private operator and has been doing
the work and putting the money in to
maintain it
um and and that's like what we'd like to
see for these future uh find owners of
these dams that that there where there's
a value to them and they can take on the
maintenance and uh capital investment
needed which has happened in this site
and it's just a good time to fully move
ownership over okay thank you thank you
thank you Senator Lang I'll wave after
they answer my question okay
um I um it would appear shortly you're
going to be flush with money in this
department so I just want to tell you
that the Mill Pond Dam owned by the town
of ospi which was topped ogre that I
heard about issues that perhaps town of
Osby could sell you back one for one
dollar
that is inconsistent with our current
strategy but I uh we will take that
under advisement but I I just want to
mention that I was told that it was
someone from your department is going up
to Osprey the next couple days to look
at that yes it was recently inspected
back in September and so they're going
to be heading back up there to see if
anything changed during these flooding
events that we had over the past six
months and I know it's not your
Department's issue but I'd like to be
informed what what you do find out about
that sure if you could thank you so any
further questions move to approved 2319
moved by Sandra Lang to approve
um 29 20
seconded by Senator delisandro seeing no
further discussion if you're in favor of
the approval of 23019 signified by
saying aye aye any opposed
non-passage unanimously thank you thank
you for your time
we will move to Department of
Transportation
23018 requests to extend the current
lease approximately a thousand square
foot of stay known Manchester and
Lawrence railroad Corridor city of
Manchester under a 10-year lease
good morning
just just press on the uh the big button
there we go
good morning thank you chairman and
committee members for this opportunity
I'm Louis Parker from the Department of
transportation's Bureau of rail and
Transit
I'm here to request authorization to
extend a lease current lease
with the outfront media for a site in
Manchester for a out a large billboard
it was originally 10 years and we would
like to add five years to this lease as
the lessee has a significant investment
and they need to uh
pardon me for forgetting the term but
it's based on the return on investment
in addition to the request for the time
I took a look at the CPI and went to our
Bureau of right away for
[Music]
um
concurrence and we feel that it's
appropriate to request an increase to
the annual rent base rent to 28 500.
we also I also have members
from out front media if you have
questions
um I submit the as a request thank you
sir thank you uh questions
for
seeing none move to approve 23 9 18.
Sandra Lang moves to approve item
23018 seconded by sender Pro
any further discussion
seeing none if you're in favor of the
motion to accept
23018 Department of Transportation
signified by saying aye aye any opposed
motion carries
there was none unanimous thank you
we have for information here
um
item 2320 New Hampshire Council on
resources and development
Surplus Land review
and we also have item 21 which is New
Hampshire Council on on resources and
development minutes of the March 9th
meeting Council of resources and
development
any discussion on those
I had a I had a chance to look at a date
for our next meeting and I'm going to
offer that we would meet on September
15th
which is a Friday
so perhaps we can put that in as as a
date and then if the senators or we at
the house have an issue we represent
included excuse me yeah would that be
what time on Friday September I'd like
nine o'clock if that seems to work for
us I've never had such a great
opportunity of senators here so we'll
stick with that
and um
I just want to thank representative
Cooter includer for filling in for uh
clerk today and I'm always very
appreciative when you step up for that
role so I thank you sir for that with
that I'll accept a motion to adjourn
second uh D'Alessandro motions to
adjourn seconded by uh Lang all those in
favor signify by saying aye aye
we have concluded our business thank you
well is that in the budget it's on or
did it go in capital budget I'm not sure